top business store is live from the Sky
News City Studio
wage inflation remains at record levels
intensifying pressure on the bank of
England
playing for the ashes and running a
business will be speaking live to
England Stuart broad about his career as
a small business owner
and pensions Revolution what are the
Chancellor's plans to reform the
industry mean for investors
foreign
this is business live with Ian King now
wages continue to grow at a record Pace
during the three months to May
maintaining pressure on the bank of
England to continue raising interest
rates the office for National statistics
said that regular average pay which
excludes bonuses grew at an annual rate
of 7.3 percent that was unchanged from
the three months to the end of April the
news has sent the pound to a 15-month
high on the foreign exchange markets but
the unemployment rate unexpectedly Rose
from 3.8 percent to four percent or
joining me now apparel he is the
director of the center for UK growth at
Boston Consulting Group bro good to see
you this morning not what the NPC would
have wanted to see no definitely not I
think they were hoping for a bit of
moderation and wage growth and obviously
as you said maintained at record levels
there are a couple of drinks which
they'll be pleased with vacancies came
down quicker than expected but still
over a million vacancies so you know
well above what they want to see and as
you said there was an increase in
unemployment which will will give them
some hope because it came from inactive
so people moving out of being inactive
back into the workforce and looking for
jobs so that helps a bit on the supply
so a little bit less demand a little bit
more Supply so a little bit of something
for them to to see moving but on the
whole not yet having effects on wages so
they will still be concerned yeah I
thought that uh fallen in activity rate
was really quite striking I mean it's
off by four percentage points or 0.4
yeah it's quite striking yeah it's quite
a big drop I think the biggest drop in
in 15 months or so so definitely uh good
to see and it's been a real concern and
I think if you look compared to the UK
compared to other countries one of the
big differences is the rise not in
activity rate and the permanence of that
rise and now we are seeing that come off
so that will give some hope both to the
government and to the NPC why do you
think the inactivity rate is falling
because obviously it crept up and a lot
of people said that was due to more
people going long-term sick post covid
is this evidence that people have been
driven back into the labor force by the
cost of living yeah I think that is a
big reason we're not yet seeing a
long-term sit come down so you know
that's not a good thing we do want to
see that come down but that is still
remaining at their record levels what we
are seeing though is retired people
parents others who weren't looking for
work now looking for work again so
clearly I think the cost of living
pressure are the pressure on households
is bring them back into labor force and
wanting to find paid work and as you say
the unemployment rate crept up I mean it
kind of implies that the people coming
onto the jobs Market are not necessarily
the ones able to fill some of these
vacancies well quite and we see a lot of
discrepancies in sectors right now you
know in the Professional Services
Technical Services sector you know wage
growth is going 10 11 and the vacancies
are are even higher and so we don't see
a lot of people filling those jobs same
and information and communication what
we do see though is that in like
Hospitality accommodation food much
lower wage growth much for your
vacancies so there is probably a
mismatch in the people coming into the
market as you say as though as where the
jobs are yeah you touched on vacancies I
mean down 85 000 in the quarter but
still above a million I mean this is
extraordinary when you've got an
unemployment rate uh this low yeah it's
it is really so you know as you say
there does seem to be that mismatch when
not quite getting the skills right you
know again when you come to immigration
being at record highs as well you know
and we still have those vacancies so it
is surprising that there is just these
this mismatch and it feels quite
structural for the UK now if you look at
some sectors education social Care
Health Care
um you know there are those long-term
problems in terms of getting workers
into those sectors even though we are
bringing in people from abroad and I
think that is really playing a part in
making this um you know one million
vacancies quite entrenched yeah I
mentioned the fact that Sterling Rose on
the back of this news I mean everyone
assumes that this gives the bank of
England no choice but to move again on
August the 3rd yeah that seems to be the
feeling and you could have seen in the
run-up to this as well Market
expectations of where the bank rate or
Peak have gone up quite significantly
you know we're over six six point two
five six point five percent at times and
so clearly people are baking in a lot
more rate Rises and I think there's a
sense that the bank of England you know
just feels it has to do something you
know it feels a bit out of control it
feels a bit like you know getting a lot
of criticism as we've seen a bit behind
the curve and so you know the the
previous 0.5 rise and maybe even another
0.5 rise to come to try and send the
message that they can do something they
will take action that kind of feels
where we're in at the moment except that
wages and unemployment stroke employment
are lagging indicators is there a case
for the bank holding fast for a while
yeah look I think there is Strike quite
a strong case for that you know we've
probably felt maybe 1.52 percent of the
interest rates so far you know it's it's
quite laggy in terms of time it takes to
pass through and we haven't seen the
full effect on mortgages either and that
side of things or on corporate borrowing
so a lot of this stuff is still to come
so you know whether whether they should
sit tight and just wait for what they've
done so far to have an effect is is
quite a strong case but I think just the
public pressure they're under the
criticism they're getting there is a
sense they feel like they have to do
something which isn't necessarily the
best way to make monetary policy but it
is kind of the reality of where we are
at the moment all right Ralph good to
talk to you this morning thank you
now as if the Nottinghamshire and
England cricketer Stuart broad wasn't
busy enough right now with the ashes the
puppy co-owns the tap and run reopened
last week after burning down last year
he's also working as an ambassador for
the accounting software group Sage which
has just launched a competition as part
of its partnership with the 100 Cricket
tournament in which one lucky small
business owner will win free advertising
and business advice worth 60 000 pounds
and I'm very pleased to say that the
England cricketer and owner of the
Tupper run Pub Stuart broad joins me now
Stuart good to see you this morning what
made you want to go into the pub sector
uh great question actually a great
friend friend of mine Harry Gurney uh
came to me years ago in 2016 and his
local pub had come up for sale and and
asked if I was interested you know we
talked in the change room a lot I was a
teammate at Nottinghamshire with him
about business and and that was
something that we really wanted to do
and it's we've evolved a huge amount
over that time it probably started as a
little bit of a hobby for myself and and
uh Harry definitely saw it as a a an
Avenue as a career after after playing
Cricket
um but the business plans evolved a huge
amount and and you know we're very clear
that we want to be a a growing business
now and and collecting a few different
pubs so along the way and delighted that
we're here at the tap and run having
been rebuilt after a devastating fire
um a year ago and and it looks
absolutely stunning so um yeah delighted
that we're we're back up and running
here it does look very nice from here
Stuart um I mean was there any doubt in
your yours and Harry's mind when the pub
burned down that you were going to have
to reopen it we tempted to walk away
yeah great question actually because I
remember so clearly it was during the
Trent Bridge test match and and Harry
called me at you know 5 30 in the
morning saying that the pub was on fire
which was obviously a huge shock and I
had to play the the rest of the Test
match so the day after I I came to the
site
um and it was devastating you know it
was a complete write-off really and
could only look through the windows
because of the damage took eight fire
engines to to put the blaze out and I
was I was quite emotional at seeing it
and my business partner Harry
um I was sort of quite interested to see
what his views were and he was so
positive straight away I bear in mind
this was two or three days after the
fire he had no doubts that he wanted to
to build it back bigger better
um you know we've had amazing support
from the local community and ultimately
when you when you own local pubs that's
what you're doing it for you want it to
be a community for people to to enjoy
each other's time and meet different
people and um Harry was so so driven and
so positive about what we could do to
make their business this even better and
and it's come to fruition and it's just
it's so special being here and seeing
um the plans come come to place have you
know been open 10 days now and we've
been amazingly supportive not just by
the local community but but from people
traveling afar as well so no it was
there was a bit of doubt in my mind with
the emotions initially but but Harry
doused those and and uh has been hugely
positive you mentioned you've got plans
to open a few more establishments I mean
one of the big challenges that all small
businesses have is is access to credit
do you think that's going to be a
problem for you down the line
yeah I mean one one line that Harry and
I always use is you know we we have to
be cautiously optimistic in this this
industry it's uh it's it's a fancy it's
a fantastic industry to be a part of and
and Harry runs it uh day to day and has
learned a huge amount over the over the
past few years particularly after
finishing playing Cricket
um but you know one thing that we love
about the industry of the people and I
think that's where it's so similar to to
sport is
um sport a lot of the time especially
playing a team sport is about the people
involved in the culture involved in it
and and the pub Industries exactly the
exactly the same as that
um you know I think it's quite difficult
to look too far ahead obviously we have
a business plan of how we'd like things
to go and grow the business whether
that's five pubs in the next five years
or ten in ten um but we sort of we need
to just see how the opening of of the
tap and run goes
um over the summer
um building up uh sort of finances and
and looking to the Future we've got a
pub um growthly in leicestershire called
the Griffin that's that's been doing
fantastically since December when we
took on so there's definitely a mindset
for growth but but we also have to to be
a little bit cautious in in the pace in
which we do that because ultimately you
don't want to ever put any quality in in
doubt and and it's important that we get
the quality spot on here before before
we look to to grow absolutely no well
you've got a week off or so before the
next test at Old Trafford um one thing
that's been raised I mean you've had a
fantastic Series so far top Wicket taker
but Tom England's Catchings left a bit
to be desired at times is there going to
be a real extra catching practice
um yeah it's a it's a funny one you know
we've been we've been excellent over the
past year with with our catching we just
uh we've put a a couple of catches down
in the in this series unfortunately it
leads it it didn't hurt us too much
money to win a game and to be honest
having played in all three ashes test
matches so far it's it's been
breathtaking stuff it's been very
emotional to play in it's been very
tiring but it's um it's been incredible
Cricket you know I think every single
game the results could have gone either
way and and when Cricket is so close
like that you do start to look at
certain different things in your game
that you can that you can get right and
you know we know a couple of catches of
mistakes have probably hurt us uh in the
in the three test matches um but we've
got two to go you know two we need to
win both and and we feel really positive
about that catch you is such an
interesting one for me and having played
a long time now it's almost the more you
talk about it the more you practice it
becomes a bit of a mental thing and and
you focus too much on it the key to
catch is staying very relaxed in the
shoulders and very relaxed in the hands
and things just happen naturally so I
don't think we'll talk about it much to
team we just have huge faith in each
other's ability that when that chance
comes we'll take it but yeah it was
looking back to Sunday it was just
breathtaking stuff to be a part of my
nerves when I'm 37 years old but I don't
think I've ever been as nervous as I was
on stuff on Sunday afternoon
um so nice to get through that we've got
a few days off meet up in Manchester on
Saturday rest the bodies a little bit
and and
um you know it feels like there's a bit
of Ash's fever around the country at the
minute and we need to jump on that that
bandwagon and keep playing good Cricket
absolutely I mean it was great seeing
you getting in the Aussies faces at
Lords after the best or something
incident I mean Gideon Hague the
Australian cricket writer wrote in the
times today that uh you know you're
you're the man that the Aussies love to
hate but he said he got gets the sense
that you're actually the people that a
few Australians now might hate to love
[Laughter]
um I must admit yeah I um sometimes I
like to just get in a little battle for
myself I knew that I had it was such an
important moment of that game at Lords
and I need to make sure I was mentally
switched on and able to do a job for for
Ben Stokes at other end so
um part of my strategy really was to
to pick a fight with a couple of
Australians to so I wouldn't be focusing
on too much technique I would just be
focusing on the ball and making sure I
could stay there so um yeah I mean part
of Ash's cricket and the the Rivalry the
history of it is is very much a great
battle out there and and both teams have
have been really stuck in this series
um but it has been you know a lot of the
players know each other very well
um there's a lot of sort of talking and
smiles we lunch in the same room you
know it's not as if there's there's a
huge huge battle going on um off the
pitch it's just you're playing for your
country I'd expect nothing less than
showing a huge amount of passion and
pride
um and you know just from being on there
on the field all the time the the energy
I'm feeling from the crowd and from the
supporters and from the cricket fans
around the country uh has been magical
so um you know we'll keep trying to
entertain and put on some brilliant
Cricket for people to love
um and keep letting us know that you're
enjoying it
we will indeed pleasure to talk to you
best of luck for Old Trafford and best
of luck with the tap and run too thank
you
[Music]
well the pound Rose to a 15-month high
against the US dollar after the wage
inflation figures out earlier this
morning uh Sterling currently now
trading at uh just over 1.29 that's up
half of one percent on the session it's
up by roughly the same amount against
the Euro single currency meanwhile more
or less unchanged right now against the
dollar on the equity market stocks in
the Asia Pacific region enjoyed a solid
session overnight after last night's
gains on Wall Street all of the main
indices in the region finished in
positive territory the knicker in Tokyo
posted its first gain in six sessions
well in Europe stocks are also largely
in positive territory right now there's
a current picture talking points today
include Diamond Truck which is ahead by
just over one percent in Frankfurt on a
trading update here in London the ftse
100 also in positive well look at that
it's just nipped into negative that's
more or less unchanged rise just about a
fifth of one percent low right now I
think the stronger pound is probably
Weighing on some of the big foreign
currency earners the health care stocks
in particular Weighing on the index
there are not many specific features for
investors to get excited about in the
main index today outside the foot seat
there's more going on the car parts make
a dialysis it's off nearly seven percent
on broker comment while pen on group the
owner of Southwest water is off by half
of one percent right now that's after
paid 85 million pounds for three new
renewable energy generation projects the
business recovery specialist begby's
trainer is off one and a half percent on
its full year results so the upside to
the house Builder gallifer try is ahead
by two and a quarter percent right now
on a trading update
the oil price well that edged higher
this morning it's trading in a really
tight range right now about a Brent
crude will currently set you back 78
dollars one cent a barrel that's up a
little over two-fifths of one percent to
join me this morning is Roger Lee head
of UK Equity strategy at investor Roger
welcome to you it's all about inflation
again this morning and those wages
numbers
oh absolutely it's all about inflation
it's all about where interest rates will
end up and that seems to be affecting
you know Sterling as you just mentioned
I mean that's clearly having a positive
impact on Sterling in terms of higher
interest rates higher interest rates for
longer and I think as you've already
mentioned I mean the markets now and
anticipating interest rates going to six
and a half percent now in the UK which
you know is obviously would be of
concern to most people if that were to
happen looking at your notes you point
out that there's been a steady uh series
of outflows from UK Equity Funds right
now I mean one or two people around town
are telling me they think the UK Market
looks quite good value at these sort of
levels well I would say this wouldn't I
um but the UK Market looks sort of
exceptionally good value now I mean we
can you know that's easy to say when it
will when that value will be
crystallized is another matter but the
UK Equity Market the footsies on uh you
know sort of multi-decade low in terms
of its valuation multiple compared to
where it trades it's on a multi multi a
low multi-decade low compared to the s p
the s p obviously always traded a
premium but it's such a wide premium at
the moment that on any metric the UK now
is sort of back to where it was in 2000
at the end of the.com bubble in terms of
its relative valuation to uh to the US
and uh so on that basis uh yes I would
agree with those commentators but in
terms of we've got earnings season
coming up for the half year stage to how
important is the earnings season for the
UK markets valuation right now well I
mean I don't want to be dismissive of
earnings because clearly they are very
important but I think I go back to what
you just you know your first question or
your first comment that really this is
all about interest rates this is all
about the valuation we put on those
earnings and that's what makes this
Market really quite difficult for most
most participants is that you're not
only having to forecast where the
earnings are going but you really really
have to pay very close attention to what
valuation you're going to put those Zone
quite interesting to note the number of
companies that are still announcing
share BuyBacks I mean Only Yesterday
future publishing big big midcap company
announced a 45 million pound buyback I
mean that suggests a lot of these
companies themselves think that their
stocks are quite cheap yes I think so I
mean that's tends to well well would
like to think that management have a
sense of what's value in their own
shares but uh history would suggest
that's not always the case but let's the
benefit of the doubt is is that if
companies are buying their shares back
they obviously can see some value and I
I think you know that's one of the
factors that's very much keeping you
know is a positive for the footsie it's
the amount of BuyBacks the amount of
de-accretization that's taking place
particularly in some of those very
larger stocks in the market which have
got very very significant BuyBacks at
the moment which are the sectors that
you're most looking out for in terms of
the forthcoming earnings season well I
mean it's what really drives the market
what really drives the footsie is so
heavily biased towards those three
sectors oils well natural resources uh
financials and and Staples to a certain
extent so it's it's those earnings that
uh we were we are going to be looking at
and I I think you know the backdrop for
earnings is probably still reasonably
attractive one has to remember that
equities companies operate in a nominal
environment an environment with
inflation and so whether you've got
inflation where it is at the moment
obviously it's a real problem for the
bank of England but if companies are
able to get these price Rises through
then their Top Line growth could look
quite attractive and that could be the
surprise going into this earnings season
well we should watch and see Roger good
to see you this morning thank you
still to come on business life what are
the chancellors ambitious plans for
pension reform mean for investors and
the particularly pension Savers don't go
away
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
our app gives you the very best of Sky
News wherever you are breaking news
videos and Analysis evidence of the
crisis podcasts watching us live take
you live to Manchester Crown News Daily
podcast all in one place and all adjust
the touch of a screen the Sky News app
download for free now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Fly Emirates fly better
welcome back another Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt last night unveiled a series of
proposals aimed at channeling billions
of pounds worth of UK pension savings
towards small high-growth companies he
unveiled a Compact signed by nine of the
UK's largest pension providers including
legal in general and Aviva to commit
five percent of so-called default funds
for defined contribution pension Savers
to unlisted equities by the end of the
decade the chancellor claimed it could
unlock up to 50 billion pounds worth of
investment if all such UK pension
providers follow suit will join me now
it's Michael Moore he's chief executive
of the British Venture Capital
Association Michael welcome to you a lot
of skepticism out there that this is
really an appropriate Target for
long-term pension savings give me the
case for well I think when you look at
the challenge facing pension servers
right now they need to generate the
returns that will actually create the
pension pot that will in time mean they
can get as comfortable in retirement as
possible and currently at the moment
those returns are not looking great when
you look at the returns that can be
generated by venture or private Equity
by businesses then you're in New
Territory where you can actually
substantially improve the return to that
now we look at 10-year benchmarks those
are much better for private equity and
Venture Capital than say they all share
of the 250 and we think that blending in
a bit more of these types of investment
will do better for those returns give us
capital for investment in UK businesses
and perhaps embed some of those
businesses here in the UK rather than
seeing them disappear off to the US you
mentioned past performance so Michael
but this has been an exceptional period
in which we've had near zero interest
rates so VC and private Equity have both
done very well I mean there's no
guarantee they'll replicate those
returns in future nobody's saying
there's going to be guarantees you're
quite right but what we need to have a
focus on is the value of the Investments
over time not a focus on the cost of
that investment we need to look at the
scale of the pension investing so quite
a lot of important announcements last
night about getting consolidation of the
pension scheme industry there are new
vehicles to do it so the idea of
different big institutions coming
together to support Venture and then the
compact nine big institutions saying
they'll up their allocation to five
percent to unlisted Securities by 2030.
some North American pension schemes are
already doing between 10 and 30 percent
so I don't think that's a an indication
of something that is risky this is about
clever sensible investment except these
big institutions don't really have much
experience of investing in private and
often in liquid assets and I think that
what was announced last night is a
sensible set of measures that get us on
the right Journey the government's made
important recent changes that mean that
the cost cap on fees went away we can
now allow trustees and others to invest
sensibly for the long term and look at
generating those better returns that
also get us that Capital that we can put
into the British economy do you worry
that this big inrush of new money from
Pension funds is potentially going to
depress investment returns I think that
this is not going to be exactly a rush
but a nice scaling up if I can borrow
the term of extra Capital into this area
there are lots of great Professionals in
the city of Elsewhere who'll keep an eye
on that the important point about
private capital is it's actively managed
we've got a 40-year success story here
in the UK we've got the second largest
Hub of private Capital expertise
anywhere in the world outside the US so
we are well placed with the expertise to
make that investment appropriately all
right Michael got to leave it there good
to see you and good to see you in person
again after a long time as well thank
you
that's it from me for now I'm back at
half past four this afternoon in the
meantime do stay tuned because coming up
after this short break we're going to be
bringing you the latest on the crisis
currently engulfing the BBC at midday
we're expecting to hear for the first
time from Tim Davey he is of course the
BBC director General will be bringing
you his comments as soon as we get them
here on Sky News do stay tuned and I'll
see you again hopefully at half past
four
thank you